chelsea mitchell is a name that uh you
may or may not know she would be a
household name if we lived in a country
in a culture where strong and brave
women were actually celebrated
we're told of course that such women are
celebrated we're instructed to celebrate
them
but it turns out that there's only a
very specific type of female bravery
that we're supposed to recognize and
honor
in fact according to our cultural
overlords the most honorable act
of female bravery is that which is
committed by males trans women
quote unquote are the most acclaimed
sort of women in the country today
and they aren't really women at all real
women take a back seat
and real women who oppose the intrusion
of so-called trans women
quote unquote aren't simply sent to the
back they're kicked off of the bus
entirely
that's been the case for chelsea
mitchell who along with three other
female athletes is suing the connecticut
interschlag
interscholastic athletic conference for
allowing males
to compete against them you may have
heard of this case
almost everyone in the country today
would claim to stand for the rights of
women
right everybody would say that but few
have had the courage to remain standing
when push really comes to shove mitchell
and her fellow plaintiffs
are among the few who are actually
standing up for women
and they have all of our cultural
institutions especially the media
stacked against them
that point was made abundantly clear
this week after mitchell wrote an op-ed
for usa today
where she's making her case making her
case against males competing against
females in sports
now the fact that usa today would even
publish that article in the first place
may seem like an encouraging sign but
that encouraging sign quickly
turned creepy and orwellian before we
get there let's let's read some of what
mitchell wrote in her editorial
uh or i should say this was her original
editorial
as it first appeared this is what she
says
uh quote it's february 2020. i'm
crouched at the starting line of the
high school girls 55 meter indoor race
this should be one of the best days of
my life i'm running in the state
championship and i'm ranked the fastest
high school female
in the 55 meter dash in the state i
should be feeling confident
i should know that i have a strong shot
at winning instead all i can think about
is how all my training
everything i've done to maximize my
performance might not be enough
simply because there's a runner on the
line with an enormous physical advantage
a male body i won that race and i'm
grateful
but time after time i have lost i've
lost four women's state championship
titles
two all new england awards and numerous
other spots on the podium to male
runners i was bumped to third place in
the 55 meter dash in 2019
behind two male runners with every loss
it gets harder and harder to try
to try again that's a devastating
experience it tells me that i'm not good
enough that my body isn't good enough
no matter how hard i work i'm like i'm
unlikely
unlikely to succeed because i'm a woman
that experiences why three of my fellow
female athletes and i filed a lawsuit
last year with
alliance defending freeman against
freedom against the connecticut
interscholastic athletic conference
because girls and women
shouldn't be stripped of their right to
fair competition okay now
everything that she's written here so
far is
factually correct morally correct
inarguable inarguable i would say she's
a woman
she was forced to compete against people
who are not women
they had unfair advantages because of
their male bodies
through those unfair advantages she was
robbed of the achievements that she had
earned
this is an utterly unassailable and
undeniable point
she also describes and i want to read
this because it
she talks about how bad the situation
has gotten
it's actually worse than i even realized
she says quote the ciac allows
biological males to compete in girls and
women's sports
as a result two males began racing in
girls track in 2017
in the 2017 2018 and 2019 seasons alone
these males took 15 women's state track
championship titles
titles held in 2016 by nine different
girls
and more than 85 opportunities to
participate in higher level competitions
that belong to female track athletes
that's because
males have massive physical advantages
their bodies are simply bigger and
stronger on average than female bodies
it's obvious to every single girl
on the track all right 15 titles
two males took 15 titles that before
have been split between nine different
girls
and these are males who we should
remember wouldn't have even
made it onto the track in a championship
meet against other males these were
mediocre unimpressive male athletes
who couldn't hack it against the boys
and yet they dominated against the girls
and by the way we we can't see inside
their minds we don't know their
motivation
but i'm gonna guess i'm gonna speculate
that this is not a coincidence
it's not a coincidence that they found
that they were mediocre and
they couldn't really compete against the
boys and then they discover their female
identity
what do you know what a what a fortunate
coincidence
can't compete against the guys turns out
i'm a girl well
here we go i don't know but i'm gonna
say
probably not a coincidence
and why do they have that event well
because the male body confers
enormous advantages in athletic
competitions against females with female
bodies
which are the only kinds of females that
exist chelsea mitchell's point is that
no matter how these boys identify
no matter how they feel no matter their
perception of themselves
the biological facts remain
and all that matters in a track meet are
the facts
especially the biological facts the
physical facts
that's one of the great things about
running as a sport i
ran track when i was in high school and
one of the things i like about it is
that it's it's
it's mono amano very very
simple can i get to the finish line
before you
that's all it comes down to all that
matters are the physical facts
am i stronger than you am i faster do i
have more endurance
and we're gonna find out because whoever
crosses the finish line first that's the
answer
um what doesn't really matter are your
feelings
so if you have a biological advantage
over somebody else on the track
that advantage is not offset by your
feelings or your self-perception
and that's the case that mitchell makes
or made anyway in usa today
that was until trans activists read her
piece and realizing that they could make
no
intellectual argument against it
resorted to their favorite tactic which
is silencing the opposition
and they especially enjoy silencing
women
i mean no nobody no group in america
more aggressively silences women than
trans activists
it's not even close
but um if they want to silence women
they can't do that without the
acquiescence of cowards in positions of
power so they complained
that the article hurt their feelings and
usa today with little resistance on
their part or pushback
summarily changed the article after
publication
and without notifying the author that
they were doing it
they just changed it in order to remove
all quote hurtful language from it
now as you recall let's go back again
read this one little paragraph again in
the original article
as written by chelsea mitchell which was
originally published in usa today this
is what it said
again quote instead all i could think
about is all all my training everything
i've done to maximize my performance
might not be enough simply because
there's a runner on the line with an
enormous physical advantage a male body
remember that okay after usa today made
post-publication editorial changes to
appease
radical trans activists it now says
instead all i can think about is how all
my training everything i've done to
maximize my performance might not be
enough
simply because there's a transgender
runner on the line with an enormous
physical advantage
you spot the difference kind of hard to
miss they remove the word mail
whereas before she says that the runner
had the advantage of a male body
now it simply says that the transgender
runner
had an advantage what kind of advantage
well who knows maybe he was wearing more
comfortable socks that day
maybe she ate a cheeseburger before the
race and he didn't
all mention of the specific type of
advantage has been erased indeed
usa today removed the word mail from the
entire article
and didn't even acknowledge that they'd
done it aside from an editor's note
apologizing for their hurtful language
and in this case the hurtful language
again was scientifically correct
language
and it was also the entire point of the
article
mitchell's original piece says the word
male 10 times
every other sentence practically
contains the word male because
that's the entire point and premise
there is no argument against trans
runners in female sports
except for the fact that they're male
that's it there's no other argument
that's that's the only one and it's all
you need
in fact the argument has nothing to do
with the fact that they're trans
that's irrelevant they're self per
trans is self perception
their self perception is irrelevant the
whole point the only point
the point is that they are male usa
today decided that it's happy to
publish her argument as long as her
argument
doesn't contain her actual argument
this is quite clearly to my mind one of
the most egregious and
outlandish cases of media bias and
orwellian speech manipulation
that we've yet seen and it really
matters
this is more than just some dumb thing
that we can roll our eyes about and say
oh there's the silly mainstream media
up to its old tricks again now this is
the kind of thing that
influences people the goal
is pretty clear it's to make it seem as
though the people who are opposed to
males and female sports or or female
locker rooms
are really just opposed to trans people
and we hear this kind of
um this is the way the media presents it
all the time the only difference is that
usually they don't they don't make a
change post-publication
in most cases the original thing they
publish is going to be framed exactly
like
the edited version of chelsea mitchell's
piece where they say
things like you see all kinds of
headlines like this that uh you know
conservatives are opposed to trans
people and sports or
there's a bill being passed in texas or
or wherever
uh that that that will ban
trans people from sports that's not the
case
that's not the case at all it's it's not
about trans
um the average oblivious american
who reads that okay they're going to
read that and think well what's the
problem here
who cares if the other runner is trans
when in reality
it's chelsea mitchell who doesn't care
if they're trans
they can identify as however they want
it's the biological reality that matters
and the goal of the left with a big
assist from the media
is to erase that biological reality
now in truth they can never actually
erase
a reality biology will remain biology no
matter what anyone says about it or
feels in relation to it but they can
create a society that fundamentally
fails to recognize
or is hostile to reality
and unfortunately towards that end they
are
succeeding listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated